we're just minutes away from president
biden's prime time address
on the coronavirus pandemic he is
expected to tout the massive covet 19
relief bill he just signed into law
earlier today
and applaud his own administration's
efforts in getting vaccines into the
arms of millions of americans
it's been an incredible undertaking more
than 95 million vaccines have been
administered since december
but i'm pretty sure biden wasn't in
office in december
or half of january so will biden credit
his predecessor tonight
or will we be hearing more of this
i would love to tell you that we
inherited a situation where there were
stockpiles and stockpiles
of vaccines sitting there that is not
the case
there was no stockpile in many ways we
are com we're starting from scratch
on something that's been raging for
almost an entire year
it's one thing that the vaccine which we
didn't have when we came into office
there really was no
plan to ramp up the supply
of those vaccines so there wasn't enough
vaccine
joining me now dr ben carson former hud
secretary dr carson how are you
i'm doing well trey good to be with you
thank you you know doc you're a lot
nicer person than i am
it infuriates me because you dedicated
your entire life to taking care of
people that has been your life
mission and the notion that a bunch of
lawyers are going to take credit
for work that you and others helped with
participated with i mean what's your
response when you hear
the chaos that they inherited
well obviously i'm very disappointed to
hear that
i know how hard people work as a member
of the task force
sometimes i wondered if certain members
of the task force
ever slept they were so vigilant
and you know to be able to get that
vaccine
in place in record time in less than a
year
is absolutely phenomenal millions of
lives were saved because of that
and the logistics of course are going to
be more difficult
at the beginning and they smooth out as
things go on and that's exactly what
happened
and you know i give the biden
administration credit
for building on what was there already
but to say that there was nothing there
and that it was in shambles
uh it's symptomatic of the times in
which we live
where the sides just can't seem to bring
themselves to give any credit to each
other
why don't we build on what each other
does rather than just
constantly criticize and try to tear
people down it's going to destroy us as
a nation if we don't learn that lesson
yeah i don't know why this can't be an
american moment i mean americans work
together to do something people thought
was impossible which is produce a
vaccine and we're getting it in people's
arms and there's enough credit to go
around i
i don't get it we got about a minute and
a half left i want to ask you about
school
openings or reopenings and whether or
not you think
students are safe with with in classroom
learning
well you know my whole life has been
around children
as a pediatric neurosurgeon with carson
scholars with a whole host of things
that we did at hud
with lead and various other things and
i'm
horrified that children are out of
school
and that is impacting the trajectory of
their lives
what they're going to be able to
accomplish and no one seems to care that
much about that
in medicine we do analysis by looking at
what are the benefits and what are the
risks well
we know the benefits are enormous for
going to school
and the risk as science tells us are
very low
so it should be a no-brainer to figure
out what to do
in these cases and these children are
being robbed
of something that will improve their
lives for a lifetime
you know let me just segue that to
what we're doing to their future in
terms of enormous debt
they're going to have to pay it back you
know the people who sit there
smoking their cigarettes and having a
good time and laughing
about all this debt that we're adding
what can they be thinking
well here's what i'm thinking speaking
of debt uh we owe
you and other physicians a debt all of
us do for doing what was impossible
which is creating a vaccine in record
time and getting it
arms into the arms of americans so thank
you dr carson
absolutely a pleasure thank you